- [Voiceover] All right, Kim.
So where we left off, Lincoln gets elected
in November of 1860.
He's not inaugurated
until we get into 1861.
Shortly after his inauguration,
you have the whole situation
at Fort Sumter, which is really
the start of the Civil War.
We don't have the first major battle
until we get to Bull Run.
And the overall theaters of war,
we have this corridor
here in the Northeast
in Virginia and Maryland.
And you also have it in the
west along the Mississippi.
And the North, the strategy is
well let's use our industrial base.
Let's use our larger population.
Let's use our navy to see
if we can essentially blockade the South.
Well the South says, "Hey
we have the home court.
"We have better leadership.
"We just need to outlast the North."
And so what happens as we get started,
we talked about Bull Run
being the first major battle.
Who kind of
comes out better in some
of these first engagements?
- [Voiceover] Well I think
it's a surprise to everyone
when the South does much
better in the first year
of the war than the North.
Knowing the major advantages
that the North has
in industrial power, in railroads,
and just in the sheer number of people,
it's very surprising that the leadership
in the South does such an incredible job
of really blocking the North's advances.
The North is attempting to take Richmond,
and Lee repeatedly keeps
General McClellan from
getting to Richmond.
- [Voiceover] Right and
then Lee actually goes
on the offensive to some degree.
The South essentially wins in Bull Run,
and they have a series of victories
as you mentioned in year one.
- [Voiceover] Right, so one
problem that the North has
is that Lincoln's generals
are just not nearly as skilled.
George B. McClellan
that we've talked about,
his idea of the South's power is perhaps
considerably greater than
the South's actual power.
As he is forever telling
Lincoln, "I need more troops.
"I need more supplies.
"Send me more things."
He loves parading his army,
but I think he was actually
a little too close to the troops himself.
He was really afraid to lose anyone,
which made him very popular with the army,
but drove Lincoln crazy
because the North comes out
with this really strong numeric
and industrial advantage.
And as McClellan delays,
it gives the South time
to build things up over and over again.
In fact Lincoln, who we
often think of as being sort
of this great-grandfatherly,
sweet character,
who has so many words of
wisdom, his letters to McClellan
are downright snarky.
He says to McClellan,
"If you're not using the army,
"could I borrow it?"
(laughter)
- [Voiceover] And is that
what historians believe too?
It looks like Lincoln felt
that the reason why year one
went in favor of the South.
And what we talked
about in previous years,
everyone thought this was
gonna be a fast engagement.
The North had all of these advantages.
Lincoln believed that maybe McClellan
wasn't being aggressive enough.
And do historians
- [Voiceover] Yes absolutely.
- [Voiceover] believe that too?
- [Voiceover] Yeah, no
I think that's true.
It's really borne out by the numbers,
that in many cases where
McClellan thought he was facing
just thousands of troops,
he was really only facing
a fraction of that.
- [Voiceover] And so that
made him be a little bit more
cautious?
- [Voiceover] He was very
- [Voiceover] cautious.
- [Voiceover] At what
point is the turning point,
at least in these early
stages of the Civil War,
as we have here in this timeline?
We go from April 1861
to roughly April 1865.
The first year,
I can draw that.
So the first year would be
roughly this.
We've had several battles after Bull Run,
but then we get to Antietam.
- [Voiceover] Right so Lee,
since he's done so well
in Virginia, he decides that he's
gonna take the army to the North.
This is the first time that he heads up
into the border state of Maryland,
and he meets at Antietam
Creek with McClellan.
- [Voiceover] And this goes
back to the naming conventions
between the North and South.
It's called Antietam,
that's the body of water,
which the North does.
This is Antietam right there.
- [Voiceover] Right well
the South refers to it
as the nearby town which
is Sharpsburg, Maryland.
And once again,
- [Voiceover] I see.
- [Voiceover] this is a big deal.
This is the South invading the North now,
taking the offensive.
- [Voiceover] Right and this is
the bloodiest day
in American history when--
- [Voiceover] Let me make sure
I digested what you just said.
The bloodiest day?
I imagine things like
Pearl Harbor and D-Day.
- [Voiceover] Right,
so 4,000 Americans died
on a single day, September 17th, 1862
when these two armies meet at Antietam.
And on no other day in American history
have so many Americans died,
not even on September 11th
did that many Americans die.
- [Voiceover] And was
this a surprise to folks?
- [Voiceover] Yeah, well I think
one of the truisms, perhaps
about military strategy
in general, is that
people are always planning
for the last war.
They're not planning for the
next war, and so they learn
from their mistakes,
but what they don't know
how to do always is anticipate
what's going to be new about this war.
And there were so many new inventions
during this time period that
really made the Civil War
an incredibly deadly war.
- [Voiceover] Yeah and you can see.
These are pictures.
These are Antietam right here?
- [Voiceover] This is Antietam,
yes.
- [Voiceover] And this looks
- [Voiceover] like Lincoln and McClellan.
- [Voiceover] Right, meeting at Antietam.
- [Voiceover] Which is incredibly bloody.
And you talk about new
technologies or new weapons,
this rifle here looks like one of 'em.
- [Voiceover] (chuckles) Yes.
So this is a war where
there's a transition
from the musket to the rifle,
and what's different about a rifle
is that inside the barrel of a rifle,
there is a
sort of spiral-shaped groove.
And the spiral-shaped
groove makes the rifle
much more accurate at a
much farther distance.
It's sort of the difference
between just hurling a
football end over end
and throwing a spiral,
so you can hit a target
at 600 yards,
which is much greater.
- [Voiceover] Was unheard of
- [Voiceover] for a musket or
hard, very hard with a musket.
So it gets the bullet spinning,
which keeps it on its trajectory better.
- [Voiceover] Exactly.
So we have much more accurate technology
and old military strategy.
If you see paintings of,
for example the Napoleonic Wars,
just involved a whole
bunch of soldiers lining up
and going toward each other.
Well when you've got soldiers in a line
and very accurate weapons--
- [Voiceover] I never got why that ever
made sense though.
(Kim laughs)
- [Voiceover] I'm not sure I do
either to be perfectly
- [Voiceover] Yeah I don't
- [Voiceover] honest.
- [Voiceover] consider myself
- [Voiceover] a great military strategist,
but wearing these
(Kim laughs)
bright uniforms and marching in step
in these kind of--
- [Voiceover] Yeah it does
- [Voiceover] seem to make
you a very good target.
- [Voiceover] Yes, yes, but
anyway, you have the rifle now,
much more
accurate
and you end up with scenes like this,
but what was the outcome of Antietam?
- [Voiceover] There are two
very major outcomes of Antietam,
I would say.
One, on the negative side for the North,
is this is a battle that
is widely photographed
as you can see.
Mathew Brady, who was the leading
photography studio owner of his time,
and it's one t.
- [Voiceover] Mathew, okay.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, very
important, only one t.
- [Voiceover] Yes, a
(Kim laughs)
nontraditional spelling of Matthew.
- [Voiceover] He sends
out his photographer
that works for him,
named Alexander Gardner,
and they have roving
photographers for the first time.
They have wagons.
And they take--
- [Voiceover] 'Cause
- [Voiceover] photography's
just becoming a used technology
at this time.
- [Voiceover] Right and so
- [Voiceover] they have
Alexander Gardner photograph
the battlefields at Antietam.
And as you can see.
- [Voiceover] Like a E-R?
- [Voiceover] That's right, yes.
- [Voiceover] Gardner.
- [Voiceover] As you can see,
this is just about as far away
from the kind of heroic paintings
of what battles looked like
that people had been used to
seeing up until this point.
These don't look like the sort of heroes
of the Revolutionary War,
like George Washington.
This is,
this is gruesome.
- [Voiceover] Gruesome.
- [Voiceover] And this
is really fascinating
'cause we take it for granted
in today's day and age
is that the effect of media
on people's perception
of things like war.
Before the camera, before photographs,
if I'm a civilian, I just hear
about these great stories,
and I see these paintings
that look very valiant
and very heroic.
But now with photographs,
you see the grim reality
of war, people just shot in their tracks.
And young men just kind of
just piled up.
It's just very dark.
- [Voiceover] Yeah and
it's a real PR problem
for the North
because this is before we
can really put photography
in newspapers.
They don't have that technology yet,
but these photographs were put on display
in Brady's studios.
He had one in Washington,
D.C. and one in New York City,
and people would go and
look at these photographs,
and it was very shocking to them.
It was a level of detail
that they had never seen.
In some cases, they
could make out the faces
of the individual men who
were dead on the battlefield.
And that just seemed beyond
what was imaginable to these people.
To think of some poor person
going into one of these studios
and seeing their son dead
there on the battlefield
made it very difficult for
the North to keep up morale.
- [Voiceover] Fascinating.